let's talk about sex we've done a whole
show without talking about sex amazingly
a new study out of Germany found that
employees who have sex frequently have
significantly higher salaries than those
who aren't getting laid at work you mean
I look I believe it includes at work and
at home
yeah the study was done for at the
Institute for the Study of labor in
Germany and researchers examined 7,500
household asked questions ranging from
how often they had sex to how much money
they made sections about sexual
orientation religion etc etc let's take
a look at some of the findings people
who have sex more than four times a week
have a 3.2 percent higher paycheck than
those who have sex once a week the link
between sexual activity and wages is the
highest among employees between the ages
of twenty six and fifty okay obviously
the first question to both of you is
when's the last time you had sex
here's the thing good deflection going
well I gotta say you said is the
Institute of Labor what is the Institute
of no [ __ ] again because people who have
sex they are happier than more confident
they're you know they're they're they
have more bravado and those are the
people that make more money I didn't
realize the Germans were having so much
sex because they're like three times a
week compared to one times a week I mean
there's people that have sex once a week
like that's very exciting
yeah sounds good it's low that's hot
that's low that's low my friends my wife
my wife and I forget it we're sexual
dynamos or machines we can't stop it we
can't stop it with the sex but I told my
wife look I can increase my income even
more with a couple of Affairs is what I
say to her even one long lasting affair
look at these figures yeah she won't go
for it she doesn't buy that you know
backs it up yeah but that's not done via
fax mean nothing to my wife yeah okay so
a to your point though is this just that
sort of people you know they always say
if you look better you also get paid
more or if you stand up straighter you
get me so this just all that everything
is just basic superficial nonsense like
we do all these studies but at the end
of the day it's like people like looking
at people and that's why they hire them
and
it must be a lot of money in study
that's what I'm thinking who comes up
with this idea look at this data Germans
that aren't getting laid well german sex
which is very severe that's why that's
why they said and those poor people are
only having sex once a week the matter
with you you once a week is is it was
exciting to you I thought that was you
know like oh and sex isn't one do the
one thing that kind of a with that
attitude you're lucky is that how you
are on a date oh never get on your back
with that attitude I don't know should
we have more sympathy for people that
aren't having sex yeah I mean I don't
know let them unless you're a monk if
you're a mom if you're a most good job I
say yeah no monks can't talk or have sex
that they can't talk during sex thank
you otherwise they can or while they're
egon mean I don't know what I'm saying
but they're references and they come
they're all excellent yeah so are you
celibate why I just asked that I
basically had nothing to do with
anything
oh I'm sorry I am NOT celibate but I
just I am I am overtaken by these
numbers yeah you're just shocked that
the people are having this much sighs
yeah that actually doesn't I mean this
made clean to my personal it's not that
much sex with a partner we're talking
about ladies and gentlemen are alone
hello if it was alone we'd all be
rolling into
[Music]